and I said for your honesty
keep this please come back we want to
win your business you should have gave
him a lifetime supply yeah what the [ __ ]
Joe and then he goes to his friends he's
like you can take advantage of this
business
the guy's an idiot the cashier guys his
hands can't feel sizes and he's talking
about jacking off the whole time
[Music]
so you guys
um what's the greatest gummy bear maker
in the world
yeah why why why I don't know that's
just what the media told me oh [ __ ]
that's like a spoon fed by the
traditional media that's what The
Gatekeepers tell you when you're eating
anything else I actually don't know any
other options I'm a Black Forest Bears
glad Forest is [ __ ] bomb no no no I
don't even know that's another option it
is
like always it's like chewy it's a
perfect texture I only like the
miniature ones
the miniature ones taste different than
the regular size what do you think is
different and I can only eat it with ice
cream oh interesting like frozen yogurt
it's called a life hack it is it makes
it harder huh yeah so you like The Chew
you want the truth I want the two you
ever think about just throwing them in
the refrigerator that's exactly what
else okay I don't think about it it's
all I do really I haven't had a non-cold
gummy bear in 10 years so maybe that's
why maybe if I throw them in the
refrigerator yeah that's why I like them
with ice cream and only ice cream if you
like them hard and chewy part of the
next evolution of human race not this
old
I'm in the future bro I make my gummy
bears cold because it provides the
perfect texture because they're already
really good texture but
Tony the fridge does something I don't I
never intended to do this but I also
like it when they like melt somewhere
and then the whole all them mixed
together and then they like Harden again
and it's just one giant slab of knot
bear but it's all flavors that's a fun
time too that's so much sugar I'm
probably gonna lose my citizenship for
saying this but once I started having
gummies in Australia Game Changer dude
yeah you've said that before that the
gummies from Australia is so different
like the textures
chewier softer like are gummy bears they
just rip apart and they're hard but then
there's it's like a perfect not Taffy
texture but it's soft I remember uh
Trader Joe's used to carry these
Australian licorice
and they were like the best licorice
I've ever had not black licorice right
now you like black licorice Studio
Jeffrey Dahmer right there the [ __ ] out
of my face dude I hear that all the time
it's like beet sugar or something smack
always says it every time we have any
candy here she just gets sad because
she's like oh in Australia it's
different it is different she's right
it's better chocolate sugars all the
snacks are just way better is it like
how New York has the best Dough because
of the water is it like that kind of
[ __ ] maybe it's something like that I
think there's a corner that's cut in
American manufacturing for most Suites
where we use high fructose corn syrup
which changes the texture and the taste
I think but then the beet sugar that
they use I think it's also the
preservatives we use because we want
longer shelf life for products here and
then they just [ __ ] crank it out so
imagine your Haribo and you know
probably you're the number one in the
world everyone loves you and [ __ ] like
everyone loves your gummy bears Black
Forest doesn't stand a [ __ ] chance
against you not a chance so a man in
Germany finds a check
uh made out is it says 4.8 million
dollars made out to Haribo
and it was lost like Haribo didn't get
the check and the guy's like oh well
that's crazy so um let me
let me destroy this check and then I'll
send proof that like hey aribo don't
worry about it you can get this reissued
or whatever because it's kind of weird
and in return so he sends a a picture
proving that that happened
and then in return he gets
a thank you gift box of candies from
Haribo which the guy's like this is a
[ __ ] cheap move yeah what the [ __ ]
wait wait what he owed he owed them four
million dollars no he just found a check
oh lost check for 4.8 million made out
to to Haribo he helped destroy that
check at haribo's request they're like
hey please yeah you know because that's
going to be expensive for us if you
don't do that exactly so then he's like
hey okay I destroyed it no problem I did
what you guys wanted and then like
here's some candy little boy thank you
like it's trick or treat not even a
[ __ ] lifetime supply awesome well
what what do you expect a lifetime
supply Anthony Lee really no I'll tell
you what I do factory tour let me tell
you maybe yeah absolutely you know me at
the factory tour something that shows a
more Grand gesture but doesn't
necessarily have to it's not like he
should get money for anything or destroy
a check but a lifetime spot is money
though you know what I'm saying that's
true you know what I did I'll tell you
what what I did all right so we had a
grand opening sale that's going on right
now in junebie where where and Waikiki
you have a 30 gram tin of matcha you get
a free drink you have a 80 gram Tim of
matcha you get two free drinks this man
bought one gram I mean a 30 gram it cost
32 bucks this one's 62 right so
goddess drinks all that stuff I grabbed
the 62 dollar one gave that to him
and then he came back and he said I
think you made a mistake sir I said what
is it and then he said I think I was
supposed to get the smaller tin and then
I and I stood there and I looked at him
and I said for your honesty
keep this please come back we want to
win your business
[Laughter]
the guy's an idiot the cashier guys are
[ __ ] more
and the up the uppers don't know what
he's doing he's giving away the business
plus he looks super tired his hands
can't feel sizes
and he's talking about jacking off the
whole time
that is nice of you to do though that's
cool man I made a customer customer for
for a couple of weeks with a king he
came back a couple days after that and
he ordered some more drinks see oh yeah
I was happy about that that's how you
get him dude he loved it but
yeah I don't I don't get it like four
million dollars you probably wouldn't
give that back to the guy you wouldn't
be like thank you for finding the check
you get to keep four million yeah but
that's cool but if I was Hasbro I mean a
hurry bro Hasbro that's a toy company
right Hasbro I think I would have been
like Yo dude lifetime supply of gummy
bears thank you very much you could you
could come over here and then grab
whatever gummy bears you want
I don't know dude because like that 4.8
million like it has nothing to do with
that guy
but if it wasn't for him he they
wouldn't have got the cash well no well
either way if it um wait they don't get
the cash
he just returns it did he reissue it no
it's not his money to them he's not
reissuing but it's too Haribo yeah it's
too Haribo which means that even if
nobody destroyed that check and Haribo
never got it they can still ask for
whoever owes that money Teresa another
one and cancel it with their own baby
but they probably did that already yeah
so like they probably already Kareem was
probably like yo if we can get this
[ __ ] check and then he destroys it
later at haribo's request why is a
reroll still using checks why don't they
do wire transfers I gotta talk to their
Department of Finance dude dude they
should just give them
just give them a bag like a five pounder
of nothing but the pineapple one the guy
will be a king
that's the best one did I did I tell you
guys the story about me and Rite Aid
yeah thing I told you that right okay
you did same feelings same feelings as
that [ __ ] oh you got in trouble yours is
a little different because you invested
so much like time and for the fans who
don't know repeat well because I I used
to have do this fun thing where I would
always take pictures at Rite Aid
whenever I would buy ice cream that's
right but then it was like a thing I
liked other people doing it too so I
would always bring whoever I'm with to
Rite Aid after we eat something like
let's go get ice cream and take photos
it was like a inside thing we would do
and then they caught on it were like yo
like they emailed me and they were like
hey we saw you just you've been taking
like all these like influencers to like
take photos with Rite Aid stuff and the
hashtags like mostly like people with
like pretty big followings
coincidentally sometimes I thought they
were gonna like hit me with like a brand
deal or something cool their marketing
person goes if you're willing to do
these deliverables we would love to like
reward you and I was like that sounds
like a brand deal it was something like
take four
like we need four photos per month uh
two video assets I think like every two
weeks or some [ __ ] for free ice cream
for uh for two free ice cream cones and
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding anytime uh
oh my God I think per per Post Yeah so
disrespectful you might as well let's
not say anything oh hilarious it's
probably a new intern that just
graduated with the marketing digital
marketing degree yeah and they're just
like oh I'm gonna get them dude they're
like Ryan we want every every any time
you're here we mean it anytime you're
here you can work the Scoops
it was something really [ __ ] that like
made me never go there again dang I
completely stopped today right in check
in on that oh and Bernie did [ __ ] up
they have one employee the receipts are
bigger than the [ __ ] employee like
there's the lines are so long you're
never getting out of there it like took
the novelty out of it completely because
I thought it was such a funny random
thing to do and it just made it so and
anybody who could Market that in a way
that would be so beneficial yeah for
sure right correct the case yeah I mean
just they could have just left me alone
and I would have probably still been
doing it yeah right right but they give
you such a [ __ ] offer thinking that like
you'll be happy because you're doing it
free anyway that's probably what they're
thinking well he's doing it for you
anyway now he gets free ice cream that
it's money that comes back to them like
I'm buying ice cream I'm buying your
product but now when you have the
liberal bowls and you have to find four
people every month to do this exactly
that and then they're gonna scrutinize
it you might not get your two scoops
we don't know if we're gonna get your
Scoops you know damn well they're gonna
be like actually can you do that again
but like on this angle and like [ __ ]
these marketing students bro chocolate
malted crunch cause like we did mint
last month and like I know that's it's
such a bad taste but you know
everybody look into it to it write it
I've never seen an ad for Reddit in my
whole life by the way I don't know if
there are any I don't think there are no
way not for their ice cream specifically
yeah no way no that [ __ ] sells itself
[Music]
foreign